[Musique]
ils nous ont dit de nous préparer au
pire s'il existe un seul moyen de mettre
fin à cette guerre interminable
ce sera grâce à toi et à ta main droite
dévastatrice
suite à côté alors autant pour moi on
est la dernière ligne de défense
on se bat contre les forces des ténèbres
c'est ça tu t'attendais peut-être à une
pancarte passe secrète
[Musique]
bonjour il me faut une pièce d'identité
mon coeur vous dit comment tu as fait de
moi une arme je voulais juste faire
ressortir ce qu'il y a de mieux en toi
[Applaudissements]
allez à mettre tes fesses on n'a pas
sauvé le monde doit un truc comme ça
elle a une compétence particulière
elle défonce tout ce qu'elle touche
tu es le seul et unique espoir de
l'humanité
royaume était censée combattre les
monstres et pas les recruter
tu me crète deux monstres du computer
déjà vu dans une classe
je dérange
contraire tu arrive juste à temps
[Musique]